a deadly police shooting in grand rapids
michigan has led to outrage in an
investigation by state police
26-year-old patrick leoyea was killed
during a struggle after a traffic stop
he was shot in the back of the head as
he was on the ground adriana diaz has
more i'm stopping you do you have a
license
the fatal encounter between the
unidentified officer and 26-year-old
patrick leoyea began as a traffic stop
over a license plate that didn't match
the vehicle's registration
leoya appears to walk away from the
officer and then resist before running
multiple videos including from the
officer's body camera his dash cam a
cell phone and a security camera
captured what happened next the two
appear to wrestle over control of the
officer's taser it deploys twice into
the ground
then as this video shot by the car's
passenger shows while on top of leo's
back the officer fires a single shot
striking leoya in the head
the grand rapids police chief released
the video despite an ongoing
investigation saying the community
needed to see what happened a taser is
not per se a deadly weapon the taser is
what would be known as an intermediate
weapon under michigan law an officer can
use deadly force to prevent death or
bodily harm they're not identifying the
officer but the seven year veteran is on
paid administrative leave pending the
investigation
after the video release hundreds
gathered to demand justice
leoya who was a father to two young
daughters was a refugee from the
democratic republic of congo in a
statement attorney ben crump who's
representing the family demanded charges
against the officer
saying in part the video clearly shows
that this was an unnecessary excessive
and fatal use of force against an
unarmed black man who was confused by
the encounter and terrified for his life
that frustration flooded tuesday's pact
city commission meeting you share the
blame the blood is on your hands too
we never had to lose someone at all
patrick leo was cut down in the prime of
his life the michigan state police are
leading the investigation when it's
finished it will be up to the kent
county prosecutor to decide if charges
are warranted for cbs mornings i'm
adriana diaz
it's very tough very tough to watch that
you can see though that there's a
struggle you can see where the officer
is afraid you can see where the where
patrick is afraid it's just
there are many many questions to me on
that that particular story and and it
ends tragically father of two uh and it
begins on something something that's so
routine